the reputation for the FBI is everything
to it protect The Shield at all cost
when uh when I was accused of making
this recording of my meeting with my
asacs which I did I was asked about it
in in my interview my compelled
interview which I was not allowed to
have an attorney actually assist me with
just sit there and watch they tried to
get me to lack Candor so they could
charge me and do a search warrant and
arrest me
um I had said yes I created that the
natural follow-up for anybody and these
are FBI agents who are who are asking me
these questions is can we get a copy of
that because I was making some rather
huge uh Revelations to them that I was
being possibly compelled to do something
that I felt was a civil rights violation
they never asked for a copy which means
they have a copy as I suspected my asex
recorded the conversation as well and
they were not worried about what they
those guys told me they were just
worried about the exposure
reputation is everything